Andrews Stanley is working on haptic
devices that you can reach out and feel
they form a kind of digital clay that
change both their shape and also their
mechanical properties to take on the
effectiveness of different types of
objects so the main part here is this
silicone membrane and it's a pretty thin
layer here and it has all these
individual pockets inside of it that
we've actually filled with coffee
grounds so it's using this technology
called particle jamming where normally
when you have a flexible membrane filled
with a granular material is very soft
and pliable but if we pull the the air
out of it with a vacuum it'll Jam the
particles together and they'll become
more rigid and as they become kind of
denser inside of each of these cells so
we have 12 cells in this array and each
one we can individually control the
vacuum level to make it softer rigid
then we lay this whole silicon membrane
on top of an air chamber here so right
now the pressure will kind of slowly
increment in small levels and then you
can see some of the cells have already
been jammed rigid and they actually
become darker when you vacuum them as
they become denser and underneath it we
can basically adjust the pressure of the
air so that the whole thing will kind of
balloon up with the pressure underneath
it and then by controlling which cells
are soft and which cells are rigid when
we increase the air pressure the soft
cells will balloon up and the rigid
cells will hold their shape so you can
kind of think of this as like pixels in
a very coarse tactile image where the
more cells you have and the smaller you
can make them wider variety of shapes
you can create while still controlling
the mechanical properties of each cell
so you can see some of the cells are
still soft whereas other ones are rigid
and kind of hold the shape that they
were vacuumed in
it's hard to tell from a 12 cell array
but it actually started as kind of a 3d
model of a pair that I had with 12 cells
it doesn't look very much like the
actual object but to actually make it
look like the object that you're trying
to recreate we're actually working on a
hundred cell array right now we can
create these artificial objects that can
be combined with training scenarios or
virtual environments such that that
object becomes a changing haptic
interface to a remote or virtual world
you
you